SCP-682 Vs SCP-858.
Could Gravity’s Rainbow finally clear the
dark cloud of the unkillable reptile, and
bring sunny skies to the SCP Foundation?
A tissue sample from 682, repelled from Earth’s
gravity at a speed of 9.8 m/s was destroyed
by SCP-858.
When SCP-682 was exposed to 858, it began
to fall away from the Earth’s surface at
the same rate as the sample.
It reached 858, but it did not disappear.
It hit some sort of invisible barrier, and
its body appeared to be slowly boiling.
This continued until the reptile had lost
50% of its body mass.
When half of its body was gone, 682 suddenly
sprouted a pair of wings similar to those
of pterosaurs, in addition to an array of
air bladders that allowed it to fly perpendicular
to SCP-858’s gravity.